[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7,8
choisir les missions qui vous donne des
idées sorties pour le week end
tout de suite le programme sommaire de
ce jeudi 13 septembre
ryder cup et j'oserais un pic de 1024
oblige le musée de la ville ne pouvait
pas passer à côté et c'est donc le sport
qui met à l'honneur dans sa nouvelle
exposition temporaire
elle a ouvert ses portes hier et nous
l'avons visité pédaler pour les journées
du patrimoine c'est le principe de la
balade à la découverte de saint quentin
en yvelines
la sportive organisait ce dimanche lucie
sauvageau responsable de l'activité
culturelle du musée de la ville nous
présentera cette animation
une découverte des sports de glisse
urbaine samedi auront lieu les vendredis
les vélodromes sport day au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
l'occasion de s'essayer à l'hoverboard
et d'autres activités encadrées par des
animateurs avec la ryder cup les jeux
olympiques 2024 du la thématique de la
nouvelle exposition temporaire du musée
de la ville de saint quentin en yvelines
était tout trouvé c'est donc le sport
dans la vie comme à la ville qui est
présentée jusqu'au mois de mars de sa
relation à son histoire avec saint
quentin en yvelines jusqu'à sa
représentation au quotidien nous l'avons
visitée
[Musique]
et
tout comme il est entré dans nos salons
via la télévision le sport s'invite au
musée de la ville de saint quentin en
yvelines
les équipes ont travaillé sur l'histoire
de l'agglomération et de sa relation
avec le sport c'est une exposition du
cou qui retrace l'histoire du sport sur
le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines et dans la vie de ses habitants
c'est pour cela qu'elle s'appelle dans
la vie comme à la ville elle se divise
en trois parties une partie qui
s'appelle la ville en sport qui retrace
du coup le développement du sport sur le
territoire des premiers stades qui était
deschamps prêté par la sncf au grand
stade qu'on peut connaître maintenant
ensuite on arrive dans une deuxième
partie qui s'appelle spectaculairement
sport qui retrace du coup l'histoire de
deux équipements phares du territoire
qui sont le golf national et le
vélodrome nationale qui nous ont permis
d'avoir de nombreux prêts afin d'exposer
du coup un vélo et différents
équipements utilisés par les sportifs
établir son régime alimentaire découvrir
le mode sportswear au fil des années et
révéler son profil sportif
la troisième partie le sport au
quotidien et plus interactive mais ça
nous propose un sport les scénographes
nicolas franches aux et stéphane
rebillon souhaité une installation
moderne des logiciels informatiques ont
été spécialement développés comme la sky
sports que c'est une carte en fait qui
présente on va dire comme un élément
complémentaire à l'exposition où on peut
retrouver les différents équipements du
territoire l'exposition sport à la vie
comme à la ville est ouverte au public
jusqu'au 9 mars 2019
[Musique]
et entre deux visites pour les journées
européennes du patrimoine pourquoi ne
pas se découvrir les gens à vélo
le musée de la ville organise une balade
à la découverte de saint quentin en
yvelines la sportive
une autre façon d'appréhender les
infrastructures de l'agglomération lucie
sauvageau bonjour bonjour alors vous
êtes responsable de l'action culturelle
du musée et dimanche c'est vous qui nous
a menés à bicyclette qu'elle a été
l'idée de départ pour la mise en place
de cette baleine comme vous l'avez dit
on est autour d'une exposition sur le
sport pour cette nouvelle saison avec la
ryder cup les futurs jeux olympiques en
2024 et l'idée c'était d'allier une
visite du territoire ou verrait les
équipements sportifs sur place et puis
une visite sportive bien sûr pour rester
dans le thème
d'où cette visite qui se déroule à
montigny et rappe sur le territoire donc
vous dites à montigny est très justement
quels sont les grands incontournables
delà de la baleine alors on va surtout
donc l'idée c'est de combiner à la fois
des cheminement cyclable et et piétons
qui soit hors des routes donc ça c'est
le première chose pour vous faire
découvrir lors de cette promenade à vélo
et la deuxième chose c'est des grands
équipements sportifs c'est il y a des
choses remarquables évidemment notamment
on va passer par le stade de courbes le
complexe sportif pierre de coubertin à
montigny qui a été fait par un
architecte qui s'appelle aigues vives
donc on vous promet présentera cet
équipement et tout ce qu'il contient
mais aussi des tas d'autres équipements
qui n'ont pas forcément de qualité
architecturale extraordinaire mais c'est
pour montrer la densité des équipements
sportifs à saint quentin en yvelines qui
est vraiment une caractéristique de ce
territoire
grâce à son histoire aussi elles sont
son héritage d'anciennes villes
nouvelles et puis aussi bien sur l'île
de loisirs sur lequel quantité de sport
se pratique pratiquement en pleine
nature alors qu'on est au coeur de la
ville le vélodrome sur lequel on
terminera qui évidemment est éteint pour
le coup un équipement accru
incontournable de cette de cette visite
une partie à vélo finissent au vélodrome
donc c'est très varié qui c'est qui peut
venir c'est ouvert à tout le monde c'est
ouvert à tous bien sûr il faut être à
l'aise à vélo pour les plus petits c'est
important on a
d'âge en particulier d'âge limite mais
il faut que les enfants soient à l'aise
et c'est ouvert à tous parce que ce sera
pas l'idée c'est de faire du sport mais
en douceur il n'y aura pas de grosse
cote est pas non plus un rythme trop
soutenu tout le monde peut la suivre
alors cette excursion sur le thème du
sport c'est une première mais la balade
à vélo c'est un peu une formule que vous
aimez bien au musée de la ville on avait
fait d'autres vous me donnez des
exemples on fait régulièrement une
promenade à vélo notamment qui s'appelle
sur les traces du roi soleil qui est une
visite à la découverte du patrimoine
hydraulique de saint quentin en yvelines
c'est à dire toutes les rigoles et tout
le réseau d'étangs qui maillent le
territoire
cette visite elle fait elle permet de
faire pratiquement le vin un grand tour
en tout cas de l'agglomération de
traverser la majeure partie des communes
de l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines et qui au départ du musée va
jusqu à elancourt
il est temps des noës on sort un tout
petit peu du territoire et puis on
revient par le nord jusqu'à la base de
leur famille l'île de loisirs pareil en
arrive au vélodrome à la fin d'accord
donc quelles sont les autres rendez-vous
du musée de la ville pour ces journées
européennes du patrimoine
alors on a des visites flash qui semble
des visites une formule de visites
courtes qui dure une demi-heure qui sont
permettre de re visiter les monuments de
la delà de la ville sont va du
patrimoine ancien la ferme du manet par
exemple à montigny à des quartiers
beaucoup plus modernes comme le quartier
de villas roi guyancourt mais aussi en
passant par les le quartier 17 mar par
exemple qui est un le premier quartier
de la ville nouvelle
et puis des des monuments que sont la
perspective de martha panne à l'entrée
du parc des sources de la bièvre ou bien
encore le château de plaisir j'allais
l'oublier
et pour pour le nord du territoire
on fait comme ça un certain nombre de
sites cédés rendez-vous qui sont sans
réservation préalable
ça dure une demi-heure et on peut suivre
l'ensemble des visites avec un bus
on ouvre aussi les réserves du musée de
la ville pour l'occasion donc les
réserves des collections qui sont à
elancourt dans la zone d'activités des
quatre arbres il y a aussi une des
visites au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines qui permettent
de voir les coulisses du théâtre des
visites à l'ugc ciné cité aussi à
skywest qui permettent de voir des
cabines de projection donc ça c'est la
première année c'est une ouverture
exceptionnelle donc je pense que ça
devrait être très sympathique et puis
bien sûr la commanderie des templiers de
lavilledieu un rendez vous classique
mais où il ya toujours vraiment beau un
programme assez riche de visites guidées
ateliers et découverte du site d'accord
qui a vraiment de quoi faire merci
sauvageau route est revenue sur notre
plateau vous êtes donc attendus dimanche
avec votre vélo au musée de la ville la
réservation se fait par téléphone au 01
34 52 28 81 ou par mail à musées de la
ville @ skype point fr place désormais à
vos autres sorties pour autres idées
sorties culturelles pour ce week end
avec pour commencer une exposition
photos plaisir en 16/9 le plaisir aux as
et passionné de photographie alexis
charles à explorer sa commune pendant
plus d'un an et immortaliser les lieux
les plus emblématiques
son travail est à découvrir dès le 15
septembre et jusqu'au 19 octobre au
théâtre espace coluche de plaisir
construire une tour eiffel en cap là
c'est ce que vous proposent les ateliers
capela de france miniature après une
balade dans le parc pour trouver
l'inspiration le centre capela de paris
vous aidera à réaliser de nombreux
monuments célèbres cet atelier de plein
air vous est proposée sans supplément au
prix d'entrée du parc samedi et dimanche
pour les journées européennes du
patrimoine
justement pour ces journées européennes
du patrimoine sur le thème de l'art du
partage vous trouverez toutes sortes
d'animations et visites dans
l'agglomération avec notamment mémoires
de trappes qui ouvre ses portes et
propose différents ateliers de la
réparer
son de livres au moulage de saut
l'entrée est libre ce samedi de 15 à 18
heures si vous êtes plus branché visite
vous pourrez désormais vous pourrez
aussi découvrir les coulisses du
vélodrome national samedi et dimanche ou
celle de l'ugc ciné-cité skywest
dimanche d'autres activités sont à
retrouver dans le programme de
l'agglomération à télécharger sur le
site de saint quentin en yvelines le 7-8
loisirs ne pouvait pas se passer de
septième art toutes les semaines patrick
jacques de dixmude se rendent dans un
cinéma saint quentinois afin d'y
découvrir les coups de coeur du moment
l'espace philippe noiret des
clayes-sous-bois nous invite à voir le
dernier film de spike lee retrouvés à
l'espace philippe noiret cette semaine
le dernier film de spike lee dont je ne
me risquerai pas à prononcer le titre
que vous allez voir sur l'écran donc se
paye qu'il revient en force et en verve
avec son dernier film et il a électrisé
la croisette cette année puisqu'il a
obtenu le grand prix du jury il
s'inspire d'une histoire vraie une
histoire incroyable d'un policier afro
américain qui s'est infiltré dans le klu
klux klan donc voilà c'est un mélange
réjouissons de comédie policière de
satire sociale de pamphlets parce que
c'est une charge aussi très ouverte
contre l'amérique de trump contre
l'actuel président américain voilà en
résumé un film d'action militante pour
ne pas bouder notre plaisir à retrouver
dans notre salle à l'espace philippe
noiret cette semaine beaucoup comme la
personne
[Musique]
et du sport maintenant avec une grande
animation au vélodrome national ce
samedi le vélodrome sport's des des
activités gratuites ouvertes à tous et
tout au long de la journée pour une
découverte de leurs nouvelles
thématiques les sports de glisse urbaine
le responsable marketing et
communication du vélodrome est venu
présenter son programme cette semaine
dans le journal
vous allez avoir justement alors
évidemment tout ce qu'on a proposé
jusqu'à présent mais comme je lai en
introduit des nouvelles pratiques autour
de la glisse urbaine donc les parcours
overboard trampoline quand on est
moindre la glisse mais ça qu'on a voulu
vraiment proposer une programmation
multi-activités donc c'est la raison
pour laquelle on on a mis en place ces
nouvelles pratiques avec pour objectif à
terme de dévoiler notre nouvelle école
de sport d'accord donc vous c'est pour
aussi cette raison là qu'on propose de
nouveaux sports savoir quelles vont être
l'intérêt de la population locale leurs
attentes
et puis on fit proposé au sein d'une
future école de sport qui s'implanterait
au vélodrome mais si vous n'êtes pas
friand du trampoline c'est pas grave
d'autres activités vous attendent
comme tous les ans le vélo club de
montigny fait la rentrée à pédales avec
la fête du vélo nocturne en famille ou
en raid plusieurs formes de balades sont
proposées de vendredi à dimanche
les piétons ne sont pas laissés à
l'abandon avec une randonnée pédestre de
10 km tous les départs se font du
gymnase ladoumègue
inscriptions sur place pour les
randonneurs et cyclotouristes en ligne
pour le vtt
renseignements sur le site du vélo club
pour un footing du dimanche un peu
différent l'auditoire de thoiry vous
invite pour un 10 km au coeur du parc de
château du zoo et même dans une partie
du safari
au milieu des animaux les inscriptions
sont complètes mais vous pouvez toujours
encouragé les coureurs à côté des
éléphants enfin pour les supporters de
baseball les cougars de montigny le
bretonneux joueront ce week-end leur
quart de finale des playoffs de première
division face aux boucaniers de la
rochelle les rencontres sont organisées
samedi et dimanche au stade jean
maréchal
michael almy d'euros reviendra sur cette
rencontre lundi dans votre magazine des
sports
c'est la fin de ce premier numéro du 7-8
loisirs merci de nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous la semaine prochaine pour de
nouvelles idées sorties
[Musique]
oh